[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL ROTH: We're going to
talk about five or so thinkers
that I write about in the book.
And I'll talk for
somewhere between 20 and 25
minutes or something like that,
maybe a little longer, and then
see what kinds of questions
you have about education today
or the argument I'm
making in this book.
I think the tradition of liberal
education in the United States
is a great resource
for the culture
and economy of the country.
And I argue that
that's a resource that
began to be cultivated really
in the founding generation
of the United States, so
with Thomas Jefferson and Ben
Franklin.
On the other hand, I
also argue that there's
nothing incompatible
between liberal education
and, let's say, massive,
open online classes.
So on the one hand, the
argument is a comfort
to the traditionalists in
higher education who really want
to emphasize what they see as
core disciplines that might be
forgotten in the rush to
practicality or vocational
education.
On the other hand,
I actually don't
argue about liberal
arts education, which
really is about a
set of disciplines.
My approach is from
American pragmatism,
which helps us see that
anything can be taught
in the framework of
liberal education.
That is, you can have
a skill-based approach
to teaching, but as long
as that approach includes
conceptual and contextual
dimensions that
look at the integrative
dimensions of whatever you're
learning, its connections
with other things,
then that would qualify,
in this American tradition,
as liberal education, which
is different from the European
notion of liberal arts,
which really said there were
certain things you just had to
know if you were well-educated.
You had to read Shakespeare,
or you had to learn Greek.
Or you had to learn
history and literature.
I actually don't think that that
is what liberal education has
been about in the
United States, which
has been about useful
knowledge, but useful knowledge
put in a broad,
contextual framework.
So I'll talk about
it in terms of four
moments in this tradition.
The first one goes under
the rubric of liberate,
and I'll talk about
Jefferson in that regard.
And a word about a commentator
on the Jeffersonian tradition,
a man named David Walker, a free
black living in Massachusetts
who wrote an incendiary
document against slavery.
I'll talk about-- the
second beat will be animate,
and I'll talk about Emerson.
The third will be cooperate,
and I'll talk there very quickly
about Dewey and Jane Addams.
And the fourth
will be instigate.
And I was pretty
proud when I came up
with these four things that
rhyme, because I'm a historian.
I don't usually get
to rhyme things.
But the dumb part of this
was that I came up with this
while I was sitting
waiting to give
my lecture at the University of
Peking about a year and a half
ago.
I was trying to
organize my thoughts,
and I said, oh, I'll
have four things,
and they'll be liberate,
animate, cooperate, instigate!
And I went up there
to deliver it,
and I realized that it was
in simultaneous translation,
and that my translator--
although she was very gifted--
was not going to
make any attempt
to find rhyming
words in Chinese.
So you get the benefit
of the Chinese version
of my book in this framework.
It is interesting to me--
we could talk about it
in the discussion session--
it is interesting to me
how liberal education,
although it's
under enormous pressure
in the United States,
is attracting adherents
like never before
in China, in Korea,
in India, where there
is a great dissatisfaction
with rote education
and exam-based education, and
a growing interest in what we
might call liberal education.
So let me say a word about
"liberate" and Thomas
Jefferson.
So Jefferson writes to his
friend-- or frenemy-- John
Adams.
He says, ours will be the
follies of enthusiasm.
Ours will be the follies of
enthusiasm, not of bigotry.
So Jefferson
realized that if you
had an open-ended
educational framework, if you
let students do what they want,
you're going to get follies.
You're going to get
overly-enthusiastic students.
I am a president
of a university.
I have to deal with things like
fraternities and big parties
and things like that.
And so I was both
intrigued and depressed
by seeing that Thomas
Jefferson, when
he started the
University of Virginia,
was doing the same thing that I
have to do on Monday mornings.
He was dealing with things
like the students were overly
inebriated over the weekend,
and they were throwing rocks
at a professor's house.
And so he said, what do I do?
Do I call the police
in town, or do I
settle this on the university's
disciplinary sessions itself?
The same kind of questions,
alas, that many university
administrators deal with today.
I'm sure you don't have these
problems at Google, even
in the well-stocked cafeteria.
But for Jefferson, liberate
meant that you got education
so that you were capable
of autonomous thinking.
Education-- he was an
enlightenment guy-- education
meant that you were able to
stand on your own two feet,
make autonomous
decisions, and you
were learning things that
not only made you autonomous
but gave you the capacity
to act in the world.
He was interested in history
and in literature to be sure,
but for Jefferson,
the model of this
was the sciences, that inquiry
should drive education,
but inquiry without stifling
questions through predetermined
organizational frameworks.
That's a clumsy way of saying
something rather simple.
He didn't want his educational
system to look like Harvard.
And that's a red thread
through American education.
How can both the
emulation of Harvard
and the resentment of
it-- Jefferson said,
what happens when
you go to Harvard
is your parents
tell you-- anybody
go to Harvard in this room?
Very nice.
Thank you for admitting that.
Jefferson said what happens--
in his day, of course,
the early 1800s-- what
happens when you go to Harvard
is your parents picked out what
you were going to major in.
Your parents picked
out your slot,
and so you went to school in
order to assume your fate.
And that was the
opposite, for Jefferson,
of what education should be.
Education should
be the time when
you discover who
you might become,
rather than having
to take on the burden
that your parents
had ascribed to you.
So at the University of Virginia
he said, when you start,
you shouldn't choose your major.
You should start with questions,
with inquiry, and over time,
because you've been liberated
by knowledge, by learning,
over time you choose the thing
you want to learn more about.
You choose the thing you
want to specialize in.
Education will set you free.
And for Jefferson,
it was so important
because he thought that
the young republic needed
an educational
system that would tap
in to the natural talents
of an increasing and diverse
population.
So he worried that what would
happen in education, as it
had happened in Europe, is
that the rich and powerful
would have a monopoly
on good education.
They would make sure that
only rich and powerful people
could go to really good schools.
And so Jefferson said-- in a
not politically correct phrase--
he said, we have
to rake the rubbish
to find really talented people.
And then the state should
pay for them to go to school.
Financial aid was
absolutely crucial,
because otherwise, rich
people would make sure
that only rich people would
go to really good schools.
It sounds a little bit
familiar, in some ways.
I mean Williams-- no, I'm sorry.
I have to make
one Williams joke.
It's a Wesleyan tradition.
But that without
financial aid, what
would happen through
educational systems
is you would reproduce
social hierarchy.
And Jefferson was
interested in the ways
that educational
institutions could challenge
social hierarchy,
allowing people of talent
but without resources
to get ahead.
Pretty straightforward.
Now, of course, you all know
that Thomas Jefferson was not
the most-- well, he was
egalitarian in some respects,
but also viciously
prejudiced against Africans,
against Indians
in different ways,
against women in different ways.
And so although I
want to emphasize
that Jefferson's enlightenment
view of education as liberation
is fundamental in
the United States,
it also had many blind spots.
But what was interesting for
me in researching this book,
because my own work
was in European history
before I wrote this book
"Beyond the University,"
is that many people took up
the Jeffersonian tradition
in their own efforts
to achieve liberation.
David Walker, who writes
just before the Civil War,
he writes a pamphlet
denouncing Jefferson.
But he denounces Jefferson
in Jeffersonian terms.
In other words,
he says Jefferson
was right about education.
He was right about liberation.
But we blacks should take
that message of liberation
and overthrow the
system of slavery.
David Walker writes, I
don't want any white people
helping us to get
free from slavery.
I want education to get
us free from slavery.
David Walker, when he published
this, became a marked man.
A price was put on his head.
People wanted to bring
him back to the South
so he could be tortured
before he was killed.
But he was-- if you
killed him right away,
you'd be able to
collect a reward.
He didn't get-- he died
of tuberculosis, we think.
But that pamphlet,
which he sewed
into the clothes of sailors who
were going through the South
and other itinerant
workers, that pamphlet
was a call to education as
a vehicle for liberation.
Frederick Douglass, writing
just around the time the Second
World War, he relates
the story of when
he was a slave-- a young
slave, a kid-- working
with a pretty, genteel mistress.
She was teaching
him how to read.
She was teaching him
how to read the Bible.
She said, look at
this little Freddie!
He can read the Bible!
Showed her husband.
He went crazy.
He said, you can't
let this kid read.
He'll never be fit for slavery.
And Douglass said,
ding, ding, ding!
That's the Jeffersonian thing.
If you learn, you are
not going to be a slave.
You'll be liberated.
You'll be free.
And so Douglass says, look at
all these laws in the South
that say don't teach
black people to read.
There are no laws saying
don't teach cows to read
or don't teach dogs to read.
It's because they
know we can read.
They know we are human beings.
They know we should
be liberated.
They just pass
laws to oppress us,
Frederick Douglass
writes in the 1840s.
So liberation is part of
this American tradition
of, or devotion to, education.
Animate, the second
of my four moments--
I'll be quicker about-- but
it just gives me a chance
to say a word about-- one of
my heroes in writing this book
is Ralph Waldo Emerson, who is
just an extraordinary writer,
and a really
important philosopher.
Americans don't always think
of him as a philosopher.
He really inspired
Nietzsche's best work,
and is a glorious figure in
American intellectual history.
Emerson, he goes
to visit colleges--
and I'm afraid it's
Harvard again--
he goes to visit Harvard.
And he's telling people,
you should get out of here!
What you're learning
here in college
is how to conform to society.
You're not learning to think
aversively, as he put it.
You're not learning to
think against the grain.
You're not learning
to be what you'd
might call today a contrarian.
What you're learning
is how to fit in.
And Emerson said, no.
Stop learning.
That's not learning.
That's corruption.
What should happen
in college, he says,
is not that you
learned by drilling
and learned to take tests.
Emerson says what
should happen in college
is that it should set
your souls aflame.
Set your souls aflame.
And what he talks
about so beautifully,
in "The American Scholar"
and in "Self-Reliance"
and in other places-- these
short essays that are just
glorious works of American
literature-- he says,
what we should learn,
what learning should be is
the process through which we
increase our ability to make
the world alive for ourselves.
You know what happens.
You walk out of Google,
down Ninth Avenue.
You go by lots of
things that don't
make any impression on you.
They are kind of
dead to you, right?
But then, suddenly, something
will make an impression.
It's alive for you.
And Emerson said,
what education should
do is make more of the
world alive for you
as you move through it.
If you walk around-- everybody
blames Google for this.
I don't know if it's true.
And if we walk around
like this, the only things
that are going to
be alive for you
are going to be framed
by this little device.
Now I guess they're bigger.
But for Emerson,
what should happen
is you should toss to
society and see what's
vital out there in
nature, in art, in music.
And you've all had this
experience, right, sometime
in your past, maybe in college,
when something that you-- music
you would have not even known
was music suddenly becomes
alive for you.
People who you would
have ignored suddenly
become interesting to you.
The world becomes
a bigger place.
And Emerson thought that was
part of liberal education.
Not just liberate, animate.
Make the world more alive.
The third moment in
my four is cooperate.
Because those first two
guys-- Emerson and Jefferson--
they're very individualistic.
They're guys.
They're really focused
on the individual self,
becoming autonomous
and liberated
or becoming capable of
making the world alive.
Towards the end of the 1800s,
through American pragmatism,
there develops another
way of thinking
that emphasizes
cooperation as part
of what education
should be about.
And the figure there that
I write about in the book--
I write about a few people.
William James is
very important to me,
and I'll say a word about Dewey.
But Jane Addams is
really key here.
Jane Addams is most
famous in American history
for founding Hull
House and being
kind of one of the founders of
modern social work, in a way,
working with immigrants
and poor people in Chicago.
But her intersection with
this tradition of education
is worth spending a
couple of minutes on.
Jane Addams was born a kind
of well-to-do Midwesterner,
wanted to go to college,
wanted to get a real education.
There weren't that many
options for women at that time.
She wanted to go to Smith.
Her dad said, no, too far.
You're too fragile.
Go to a convent school.
So she goes to a convent school.
She's not religious.
She's not really anti-religious,
but she doesn't really
feel the vocation.
And so she goes to the school.
She does very well.
And she finishes up.
She's really, really smart.
But her father says, no, I
don't think-- you're a girl.
You don't have to go to
a university or college.
But just around
that time, he dies.
And so there she has this--
and she inherits this money.
She could do what she
wants, one would think.
But since I spent most of
my life working on Freud,
I realize that the most
powerful parent is often
the dead parent, the parent
whose wishes you follow
even though they're not there.
This is a basic psychoanalytic
tradition or myth or law,
depending on your
view of such things.
And so Jane Addams,
when her father dies,
respects his wishes and says
I'm not going to go to college.
But I'm going to
learn in other ways.
And so she has money.
She travels.
She really does educate herself.
She has an entourage
of other women
who are interested in learning.
And at some point,
she realizes something
what she calls the
snare of preparation.
And you may see this
among your friends.
Or maybe here at Google,
you may see some of this.
People who learn so many things
that they become less and less
capable of doing very much.
They kind of get overwhelmed
by what they know.
Yeah, you're laughing.
I guess that you know
people like this.
In universities, I've
seen it once or twice.
And so Jane Addams gives
this great example.
I want to share it with you.
She says she's walking
down the street-- I think
in London-- she's
walking down the street,
and she sees a guy
hit by a carriage,
a horse-drawn carriage.
It knocks him over.
He falls into the street,
and he's in distress.
She immediately thinks
of a poem by De Quincey,
who was thinking about
something in Homer
that was about the inability
of a person to act in relation
to someone who needs help.
You see the circuit, right?
Instead of just saying,
get an ambulance
or call the cops or what
can I do to help you,
she thinks of a poem about
a poem about the inability
to call for help.
She calls this the
snare of preparation.
And it's a lovely phrase.
She says, I've lumbered
my mind with literature.
It's so cluttered.
And what I want to do, she
says, is take what I've learned
and put it to work in the world.
Preparation can be a
snare if you are never
really going to act on it.
I guess it's like being
intellectually muscle-bound.
If you go to the gym,
you see sometimes
people who are so
muscle-bound, all
you can do is look
at their muscles.
They're not really
good for anything.
And that happens
intellectually, too.
People get intellectually
muscle-bound.
And she says that one of the
attributes of this inability
to act is also an
inability to see things
from the perspective
of another person.
Jane Addams was very
interested in how
you can have very
smart people gathered
around a table, gathered
around an issue,
and they seem incapable
of compromise because
of their unwillingness
to sympathetically enter
into the way of thinking
of another person.
She calls the talent
for overcoming
this sympathetic interpretation.
You probably know people
who are very good at this.
If you go to a meeting
and people are really
arguing about
something, like what's
a tactic they're going
to use, sometimes there's
a person in the room
who is able to say,
if we do some of this and
some of that, you have
a point in this way, you
have a point in that way.
And they're not
merely fudging it.
They're actually
advancing the conversation
into action that
will be productive.
What Jane Addams worries
about in universities
is that we sometimes
show how smart we
are by showing how
intransigent we can be,
how we get stuck in
our own perspective,
and that, instead, she looks
for a kind of intelligence that
would be exemplified in
our ability to see things
from someone else's perspective.
Cooperation as an important
vehicle of real education.
William James, who was a fan
of Addams's-- and they were
in a mutual admiration
society, I guess--
William James talks about
this as overcoming a certain
blindness.
He wrote an essay
based on a lecture
he gave to teachers called
"Overcoming a Certain Blindness
in Human Beings," where he
says-- he tells a story.
He's being shown some
settlements in North Carolina
out in the woods.
And he's looking at
these settlements
where the people have just kind
of chopped down the forest,
and they're burning
and making clearings.
And his driver is going along,
and James is like, oh god,
this is horrible.
What happened to the
beautiful nature in the woods?
And then the driver turns to
him and says, isn't this great?
Can you see what
we've accomplished?
We've created homes.
We've created farms.
And James suddenly
realizes that he's
been blind to what
this driver sees.
And just like, he says, if
the driver came to Cambridge
and saw William James sitting
in his room reading his book,
studying, he would
say, oh, that poor guy.
He must be being punished.
He'd be blind to
James's reality.
So James says, as
teachers, how do we
enter into someone
else's reality?
How do we overcome
blindness so that we
can engage in cooperation?
So we've gone from autonomy
and liberation in Jefferson
to animation, making the
world more of an alive
place, in Emerson,
and cooperation
in Jane Addams and James.
And now for the last
word, instigate, I
want to use, as a
bridge, John Dewey.
And I end with Richard Rorty,
who some of you may have known.
He was a philosopher at
Princeton and Stanford
and UVA, a teacher of mine
when I was at Princeton.
What Dewey said--
Dewey read Jane
Addams with great
admiration and affection,
and Dewey thought we should be
emphasizing not just autonomy,
we should be emphasizing
interdependence.
Dewey would not be surprised
by network theory today.
For Dewey, the
search for autonomy
was a kind of
American pathology,
that what we should be
searching for and exploiting
is greater interdependence,
because that's
where great things happen.
And Dewey emphasized that
education should always
be dealing with the
problems of human beings.
It should never retreat
from the social, political,
and scientific spheres
into esoterism,
because that was a failure of
connecting ideas to action.
And for Dewey, as a
pragmatist, the only reason
to learn new ideas was to
create new habits of action.
That is a fundamental
pragmatist principle,
that what we learn when we learn
new ideas are habits of action
and that habits
of action are what
make us more liberated,
more able to animate.
It's all about
activity in the world,
and not just about
accumulating facts.
Dewey here is, in some
ways, echoing Ben Franklin,
who bemoaned the
state of education
in the late 18th century.
Franklin said, all you
learn at these fancy schools
is how to exit a
drawing room properly.
You learn how to
put on your tie.
That's all you learn at these
fancy schools, Franklin said.
But Franklin said-- not like our
Silicon Valley friends today--
Franklin didn't say, like
those guys say today,
don't go to school.
Just learn how to code.
Don't go to school.
Just learn how to make an app.
Just learn how to do a startup.
He didn't say that.
Franklin said, don't go to
a school where all you learn
is how to drop names
and recite facts.
Let's start a reading school.
Let's start a science club.
Let's start an
educational project
that will broaden us
and not narrow us.
Broadening rather than narrowing
is the key to this tradition,
and Dewey picks up on that.
Broadening-- so a
problem in philosophy
is a problem for human beings
and not just for philosophers.
A problem in history
is a human problem
that is informed through
historical study,
not just some facts you
learned so you could recite
to impress your friends
or your teachers.
And so that move
towards human problems,
towards social issues, ends me
up with this term, instigate,
that Richard Rorty used to
talk about higher education.
He said, what higher education
should be mostly about
is giving us a
capacity to challenge
the prevailing consensus
to instigate change.
Rorty was rigorously
anti-consensus.
I remember when E.O.
Wilson published
this very popular book
called "Consilience," which
is about how all science and
humanities can come together
into a happy harmony.
Rorty said, harmony, bah humbug.
You don't get progress
through harmony.
You get progress by
challenging consensus and then
necessitating new
modes of cooperation
to build a new consensus that
someone else will challenge.
You don't want consensus.
You want challenge, inquiry.
You want to instigate change.
Science and the humanities
are about challenging
the prevailing wisdom through
inquiry, instigating change.
And so this liberal tradition of
education in the United States
is pragmatic because it is not
about acquiring a set of facts.
It is not about assuming a role
that your parents or someone
else has set up for you.
It is not about
supporting the status quo.
Liberal education
in the United States
has been about increasing our
ability to stand on our feet,
work with other people,
animate the world,
challenge the
prevailing consensus,
because that is how
innovation and positive change
can take place.
Today, that tradition
is under great pressure.
As I'm sure you know, I
published a little piece
earlier this fall
in "The Daily Beast"
called "How to Destroy American
Higher Education," which
is about the retreat from
this tradition towards only
technical fields, and
especially for only
some people who only
need to know one thing.
I think that is going to
result in the impoverishment
of American thinking
and diminishing
our capacity for innovation.
It is true that liberal
education shouldn't
be about the same things
that would have been taught
100 years ago or 50
years ago, for sure.
But it should still be, at
least in my hopeful view,
it should still be about
challenging the prevailing
consensus through
cooperation, liberation,
and making the world
more vital, animating it
for ourselves and for
the people around us.
So thank you very much.
I'm happy to take
questions if-- questions?
You've been so attentive.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you relate
the early years of education
by Jefferson, et
cetera-- correct me
if I'm mistaken in
my understanding,
but a lot of
education at that time
was geared to preparing you
for the law or the clergy.
MICHAEL ROTH: Right.
That's a great question.
So Jefferson was
rigorously anti-religion.
And so when he founded UVA,
he wouldn't let any chapels
on the campus,
and he didn't have
a place for the study
of religion at all.
So for Jefferson, when I say
he rejected the model that you
know what you're going to
study when you get there,
it was both-- either
it be a minister
or a judge or a lawyer.
And so for him, it was
inquiry-based education,
which meant you couldn't know
what you were going to do yet
because you didn't
start the inquiry yet.
And that meant
being open to what
he called all forms
of useful knowledge.
And so he was very interested
in astronomy, in agriculture,
in investigations
of the natural world
and in politics, that would
result in further inquiry
and different kinds
of work after you
had finished your studies.
So that was against
the grain, for sure,
of higher education as it
was practiced in New England.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So how do you
think that universities
are doing with regard to
these four philosophies?
How do you think Wesleyan,
the institution that you lead,
is doing?
Are these philosophies
prevailing?
And how learning offerings
are constructed, developed--
MICHAEL ROTH: Absolutely, yeah.
I think that at a
place like Wesleyan,
these four things
are very strong.
I think they are unevenly
distributed across the campus.
So for example,
cooperation, which we all
know is such an important part
of the work people are going
to do after they
leave the university,
is probably not as prominent at
Wesleyan and a lot of schools
as it should be.
I teach history and
philosophy classes.
And I give you an assignment.
You write a paper.
I get it.
I give you brilliant comments.
But I give it back to
you, and that's that.
No one else sees them.
And people aren't
working enough in teams.
People aren't learning
the skills of cooperation
as much as they can.
There's more of that at
Wesleyan than there was before,
but there could be a lot more.
In the sciences, of
course, you do have that
because people work in labs.
And so they do work in teams.
And we find more
and more the desire
of students to work in
concert with one another.
So what are the challenges?
It's kind of a dumb example,
but it's an easy one.
So I teach a class with a
hundred some odd students now
on film and philosophy.
And at times, especially
if I'm droning on too long,
I'll say, OK, we're
going to get into groups.
I want you to come
up with an answer
to the following question.
So everybody can talk,
and the chairs don't move.
They're all geared to everybody
sitting there watching
the professor, which gives
me a narcissistic thrill
twice a week.
But it's not great
for education.
You'd want more of that mixture.
We are creating
MakerSpaces now, where--
there's a strong
desire of students
at a place like Wesleyan
to immediately start
thinking what I can build
with what I'm learning.
That could be an organization.
That could be a
computer program.
That could be an object.
And I think that's a very--
I find that exciting, given
the pragmatist views that
I've been describing to you.
I think a lot of schools
now are trying to figure out
how they can maintain this
tradition while also answering
the anxiety that a lot
of students and parents
have about what are they going
to do when they graduate.
In the book I say, in this
book "Behind the University,"
I tell the story that--
when I was a kid,
the movie "The
Graduate" came out.
Has anybody seen "The Graduate"?
Some of you've seen it?
Oh, OK, so some of
you have seen it.
In the early part of the
movie, Dustin Hoffman
is the main character
in the film.
He was a young guy at the time.
He's, I guess,
graduated from college.
He's confronted by I think it's
his uncle, and his uncle goes,
I got one word for you.
Plastics.
Plastics!
And he'd say, uh-huh.
Uh-huh.
So today, it would be apps.
Or, I don't know, startups.
But when that movie came out,
everybody who saw that scene
laughed at this
idiot who was a jerk.
He was an old fart jerk.
You laughed at him.
Today, people would
say, oh, really?
OK, apps.
That's the feeling I get, that
today people are so worried
about-- and there's good
reason for you to worry--
about their economic
prospects, that they're
looking for great shortcuts,
which may actually
tend to undermine
their abilities
in the economic sphere.
So schools are trying
to do a lot more
to show how you can translate
what you're learning
on campus to what
you're going to do next.
I think that's a good thing.
I think the good thing is
that people shouldn't just
go to college as an
interruption in their life,
like I want to have
three or four great years
and then I go do other stuff.
College-- one of my
predecessors said,
if these are the best
four years of your lives,
we will have failed
you, because I
don't want you just
to be nostalgic.
I want you to say I'm
using my education.
And we, as professors
at colleges,
should actually help
students figure out
how they're going to translate
the theoretical computer
science that we teach
at Wesleyan to what
they might do next.
Not just skip the
theory, but to always
be thinking about can
you translate this
into other [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I had a
followup question.
So I went to University of
Michigan [? with a major in ?]
political science and a minor
in Latin American studies.
No plan, really, [INAUDIBLE].
And I, luckily, have ended
up at a great company working
in marketing, but I have a
much younger step-sister.
And she's in middle school now.
And when she talks to me about
what she might want to do,
I have a very hard
time reconciling it
with the experience
I had and the love
I had for learning sort of
for the sake of learning,
with a recommendation
for her, because it
seems so impractical to me now--
MICHAEL ROTH: You're
an old fogey now, huh?
AUDIENCE: I know.
And so but my question
is more-- in Europe,
you see kids going
off to college
who seem a bit more
prepared, with experience
or a sort of
practical internship,
and things that they've
done to explore maybe
a little bit earlier what they
might want to do, it seems.
Versus, in the US,
you kind of get there
and you have your two years
to try and figure it out
before you declare your major.
And I'm just wondering,
is there a way
we could do something
better before you actually
get to college to help prepare
kids to think about what they
could do afterwards, even
if they decide [INAUDIBLE]
more liberal arts major?
MICHAEL ROTH: It's
a great question.
I do think the European
model does really
decide-- people have
to decide what they're
going to do with their
lives very early.
And some people, they're just
not going to get the education.
So I think about this a lot.
When I was finishing
college in 1978,
the job market was
far worse, I think,
than it is today actually.
And my parents
didn't go to college.
They found this whole thing
kind of very befuddling,
that I was studying
philosophy and history.
And I told my dad, who was
a farrier, that I wanted
to go to graduate
school, I thought.
But I was worried because I
didn't know any professors that
weren't my own teachers.
So what are you
going to do with it?
And my professor
said, there's no way
you should go to
graduate school thinking
you're going to get
a job in academia.
There were no jobs.
And so you can go for education.
If you get a
fellowship, it's OK.
But don't think
you can get a job.
So I remember
telling my dad this.
And he said to me, well,
you know how to make money.
I washed dishes in college.
I had an uncle who
was a cab driver.
You see, I've got connections.
And so he said,
if you don't try,
you're always going to wonder,
what did you really love to do?
And if it doesn't work,
you'll figure it out.
You'll figure out
how to make money.
Now I thought--
in retrospect, I'm
thinking to myself, my god,
what a brave thing to say.
It was so liberating as a kid.
I asked him about this
at the end of his life.
He said, I don't remember
telling you that.
That's the kind of guy he was.
He was like, I wouldn't
have said that!
He was a tough guy.
And I think part of the
answer is economics,
that America is a much
more unequal place
today than it was when
I was leaving college.
And so there is
a legitimate fear
that, if you don't make it,
you are really in dire straits,
rather than being in this
middle range, which is eroded.
But I think it's also that
people-- my parents expected
I might have to struggle.
A lot of the parents I
talk to, they-- their kids
have never had to struggle.
And they don't want them to
start struggling after college.
And they want more certainty.
And I don't know.
A lot of you probably
majored in computer science
or other things that were
related to what you're
doing now, but a lot
of you may not have.
And I think the ability
to explore new things
has enriched what we wind up
doing in such dramatic ways
in this country for such a
long time, that to cut that off
and think that we are going to
be more successful if we have
more specialization,
I think is a mistake.
I think what we'll
have are specialists
who become obsolete
more quickly,
and we will have less
intellectual resources
to draw upon for
creative change.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't it-- sorry.
A really quick followup to that.
So how do you think maybe
certain institutional faculty
needs to change
and support that?
Because student
debt, for example,
is a very scary thing now.
I think interest rates have
gone up-- well, not all of them.
MICHAEL ROTH: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Student debt is scary
even without-- yeah, yeah.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: So I wonder
how-- what needs
to happen so that kids can
feel more secure taking over.
MICHAEL ROTH: Yeah.
That's a great question.
And that's the onuses
on schools like mine,
which becomes so darn expensive.
So we have a lot more
low-income students at Wesleyan
than we did 20 years
ago or 15 years ago.
And we have a lot of
very wealthy people,
but the middle ground is
eroded, because if you're not
poor enough to get
a big scholarship,
you may also not be rich
enough to afford to go.
And so we need colleges
and universities
to find ways to contain costs.
And we've been doing
that at Wesleyan
for the last few years.
And I think a lot
of schools, it would
be in their interest to do that.
But part of the answer is also
that the state and governments
have massively retreated from
supporting education, making
it a lot more expensive
for a lot more people.
And I think that's
unconscionable.
And that's a political decision,
to spend money on other things
and not on education.
And I think some of this
call for vocationalism
is coming from people who have
made it impossible for folks
to go to community colleges and
to state universities, which
have become much more expensive.
The growth in fees
at state universities
far outpaces the privates.
And the student debt is
also driven, of course,
by a lot of for-profit
institutions
that have no intention
of graduating students,
but they can just claim tuition.
So there are things that
the government could do.
There are things
that schools can do.
The reason I taught
these MOOCs is
because I wanted to see if you
could do something much more
efficiently.
It wouldn't be the
same as just meeting
with a group like this size
and having the conversation.
But I've taught 150,000
people in the last two years
online, as opposed
to the hundred--
my big, massive class
at Wesleyan is 100 kids.
And I think that's a very
interesting experience.
It's not the answer to
all of these things,
but experimentation
and scale will help us,
I think, make the investment
in education less risky
for students.
Yes.
One, two.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a huge
liberal arts proponent.
I went to a liberal arts
school, and every time
I just think, especially
in the computer age,
it is completely
an essential part
about just becoming
a better human being.
But I have seen
the reality of-- I
guess it's not to say that--
I have seen the reality
that, because of internet,
because of Google,
data is available everywhere.
MICHAEL ROTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what that means
is that specialization--
or commitment, shall we say?
Rather than
specialization, commitment
becomes really important, even
for a very liberal arts person.
MICHAEL ROTH: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I want to be
a better human being.
There's a lot of
other stuff that
can help me make
decisions, but I also
want to be going
into new territories
and exploring new things within
that field, because you want
to be actually contributing,
rather than just talking.
MICHAEL ROTH: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Like if you want
to join the [INAUDIBLE],
you have to be very specialized.
If you want to actually
make a difference,
you have to know
your stuff, which
is why-- as a result
of this data, internet,
and world coming
closer together.
So have you seen very
specific initiatives
that your university or other
college leadership teams
have done to kind of help
the liberal arts tradition,
but specifically really
work towards people
who are a little bit
more better prepared?
MICHAEL ROTH: Absolutely.
I think a lot of schools--
and this won't be a surprise
to you-- have responded to
student demand for internships,
for example.
So they start very
early figuring out
if they can translate what
they're doing on campus to what
they're going to do off-campus.
This is good for businesses
that get inexpensive labor,
in some cases.
And I must say, I
resisted it for a while,
because I thought they should
be paid a decent wage--
and some companies do-- but
I see that students really
want-- even though they
want that broader education,
they want the capacity to
connect it to other things.
That desire to connect, I think,
is part of this tradition,
and can be very important.
Specialization within a
liberal learning tradition
is important.
In other words,
you don't want just
to be a jack of all trades
and master of none, right?
It takes real skills to do work
in any variety of fields today.
And that may be language skills.
That may be technical skills.
That may be experience
over long periods of time.
And so I think our colleges
and universities are aware
that, while you're
giving people breadth,
you also have to
give them skills
so that they can
continue to learn.
The point of this book
"Beyond the University"
is that the university
should give you the ability
to keep learning, and not
just a smattering of things,
but habits of mind
and spirit that
keep you learning so
that you can go deeper
into subject areas and not
just scatter across them.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So to continue along
the line of thinking in regards
to, I guess, placing the
burden of financial pressure
on parents of students
who are worried
of the economic realities
the students will face
after college-- how
do you negotiate
that ideal with the
financial realities
that the university encounters
on a day-to-day basis?
MICHAEL ROTH: Well,
I'm going to ask you
all for money before you leave.
No.
It's a great question.
I mean, I'm in New
York for fundraising.
After I leave today, I'm going
to a fundraising campaign
meeting for Wesleyan.
And most of the money we
raise is for financial aid.
So it just is kind
of straightforward
economic-- we depend for about--
more than 2/3 of our revenue
comes from tuition.
We would be able to do a
lot more if we depended less
on tuition.
We would have greater access
and more research opportunities.
That's just to take two things.
And so one of the
things that I think
can be very dangerous for
American institutions is,
in the search for
good, strong tuition
dollars and good,
strong donations,
to just cater to the wealthy.
And Wesleyan has
this long tradition
that even the wealthy people
who come to Wesleyan, they
don't want to be among
only wealthy people.
They realize that, for
them, that's not going to--
they didn't want to
join a social club.
They want to join
a diverse community
where they'll learn from
different kinds of people.
And so the pressures
at places like Wesleyan
is to balance access
and the investment
in high-quality programs,
because most of our budget
is going to compensation.
And teachers are
certainly not overpaid
at a place like Wesleyan.
And they work best when
they work in small groups
with students.
That's expensive.
How to combine that
with, let's say,
the ability to do
deliver lectures online.
I mean, I do think,
before too long, no one
will have lecture classes at an
expensive school like Wesleyan.
All of that will
be done elsewhere.
And then when you're there, you
really are working in teams.
You're working in small groups.
You're getting the
most out of it.
There are efficiencies
we will gain.
At Wesleyan, we
started-- and you
may remember this--
we started showing
how you can get a three-year
diploma with the same number
of credits and then save
20% off your total tuition.
I did that when I
was a student to save
my grumpy dad some money.
And he was unimpressed.
But most students don't
take advantage of it,
even though it really is a
great economic-- it's not
that hard intellectually.
You just work in the summer a
little bit, and in the winter.
But people really
love being there.
So we are-- I'm trying
to create more avenues
for more efficient education
that doesn't sacrifice
the breadth of the education,
but more access points that
will be more efficient
and cost-effective.
Was there a hand back here?
No?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
We had some [INAUDIBLE]
learning [INAUDIBLE] And many
[INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL ROTH: You need
scaffolding, right?
To build something,
you need scaffolding,
and memory work is a really
important scaffolding for this.
So if I sounded like I was
saying no rote learning,
I misspoke, because there is
a dimension of just exercising
these faculties
that is key, just
like when you're learning
to play the piano.
I think, as
Thelonious Monk said,
there are no wrong
notes on the piano.
But that may be good when
you're Thelonious Monk,
but when you want to
learn how to do scales,
you want to learn
to do theory, there
are things you
just have to learn.
Muscle memory,
mental muscle memory,
that's really important.
I don't know how
you'll feel about this,
but just last night I read
this article in "The Atlantic"
mobile that says, "Is
Google Making Us Stupid?"
This is not the first time
this title has been used.
But it's about this.
The article is about people
who use GPS all the time get
lost in their own bathroom
kind of thing, right?
And people who just
use calculators,
they don't even understand
what multiplication is,
let alone how to do it.
And so the ways in
which our machines
replace the exercise
of our faculties,
this article is pointing
at, is dangerous.
So obviously, you don't want
to throw away the machines,
but you want to use them in a
way that enhances your capacity
rather than replaces
your capacity.
That's the sweet spot.
Thank you all so
much for coming.
It was great to talk with you.
[APPLAUSE]